automatically when I think of American
TV ads I feel like I just think of the
Super Bowl
weirdly sexist or bit racist or
homophobic watch some ads Black Angus
beef and bacon
so text it's Texas versus Mexico
totally weirdly stereotypical cliche
there's a lot of flesh I don't even know
where to begin I got no idea what this
has to do with burgers are they playing
on the border
I like those Cowboys because they were
more interested in their burger than the
whole women and I can relate to that
last same they just slept a cello oh I
just want to go and join my my local
feminist crew now I've never seen a
Hungry Jack's out like this and cialis
for daily use helps you be ready any
time the moment is right I saw what kind
of pharmacy I know exactly what this is
also I can't get an erection I know
exactly what this is
side effects may include headache upset
stomach delayed backache or muscle ache
to avoid long-term injury get medical
help right away for an erection lasting
more than four hours
that was like 90% all the health risks
that are associated with that Med you're
gonna get hives rashes swelling the lips
tongue or throat you'll bleed from your
anus oh well you know what you'll get an
erection forever ask your doctor about
cialis for daily use in a free thirty
tablet trial you can get free boner pill
trials in the US I think that's great I
didn't get on an ahkam timbal not the
bynars
this is gonna be racist BailBonds oh my
god bed oh my god I mean I've never even
heard of a bail bond it seems like a
very strange concept that's not how the
law works so it must be a pretty huge
market for there to be such an age that
you can get dropped home in a pink
Hummer I have no idea what I don't know
what we just want a really cool like you
know this little sucker come on which
one is he I don't think I can do this
it's easy just point to him without you
gonna catch me keep your mouth shut
Oh keep your mouth shut I'll get out
he's like dog making light of domestic
violence a little racist
everyone in this jail is either black or
cargo who gave that the green tick and I
hope that they're fired it out back I
started off with a light healthy
appetizer this is Jemaine Clement is
that the guy from flag on fire the
Conchords and he's sick
talking like he's Australian he's from
New Zealand he's not Australia you know
we are different Australians and Kiwis
are very different you imagine what it'd
be like if like Australia didn't add and
it was all about Americans but instead
of costing Americans would just cost
Canadians yeah hi I'm Bob I am running
running for Iowa's open seat in the US
he wants to be a politician
oh what a mentor [ __ ] is noting if you
are the sexual predator and sociopath
who murdered my sister Lynette you come
to my front door to do harm to my girls
I'm gonna use my Glock to blow your
balls off that's not real that's just
call me real that's a baby like you see
on South Park barely heard any
Australian politicians pledge to blow
someone's balls off the only good thing
about this ad is the dog that's a cute
dog confirmed a lot of what I thought
about America which is a lot of messed
up stuff going on I feel like I need a
stiff drink after all of these ads I
would absolutely want all of these out
of Australia yeah I wouldn't even watch
TV I would just just watch watch ads of
course these ads don't represent the
entire American population but from what
I've seen it seems like politicians love
guns every man in America has a erectile
disfunction
and everyone needs legal representation
for breaking some kind of law American
ads might be crazy but they're fun and
I'm pretty sure I love it